the movie is set in england during the
medieval ages at the start of the movie
we are introduced to the king's
beautiful daughter lady miriam she is
inside the royal bathroom singing
beautifully just then her maid broom
hilda approaches her and asks her to get
ready when lady marion gets up from the
bathtub it is revealed that she is
wearing a chastity lock it turns out
that her father the king wanted to
protect her from evil men so he
safeguarded her assets with the lock
unfortunately the key has been long lost
and marion has been desperately
searching for the man who can open her
lock in the next scene we see a group of
men dancing to hip hop music one of the
dancers sings about how prince john and
his sheriff have taken over england and
are imposing heavy and unfair taxes on
people elsewhere in khalil prison in
jerusalem we are introduced to the main
character of the movie robin hood he has
been apprehended for fighting in the
crusades and is being taken to the most
notorious cell of the prison there one
of the guards asks him who sent him
there but robin refuses to answer as a
result the guard takes out a tongue
loosener and punishes him with it
however robin still does not budge tired
the guard chains robin next to a
prisoner named asnes mentioning that he
will be back for interrogation again
after he is gone the two prisoners
introduce themselves and become fast
friends while robin is imprisoned for
something serious as sneezes locked up
for simply jaywalking soon they come up
with a plan to escape and strike the
metal bar which is holding their chains
luckily the bar breaks and they are able
to set themselves free the duo then
frees everyone inside the cell and
collectively all of them escape through
the ventilator in the next scene robert
and a sneeze are on the beach where
robin expresses his gratitude towards
destiny is for helping him escape as a
sign of friendship he promises to help
him in any way possible hearing this as
sneeze takes out a picture from his
pocket which belongs to his son achoo he
then hands over the picture to robin and
requests him to look after his son who
is in england surprised robin asks how
achoo ended up in england to which a
sneeze replies that he's an exchange
student being a man of his word robin
promises to look after at you and
departs the place however instead of
traveling on a boat like a normal person
would he swims all the way from
jerusalem to england after reaching
there he gets on a horse and proceeds
towards his house surprisingly on the
way he sees some soldiers beating an
african boy robin quickly deduces that
it's atsu as there are no other africans
in the area he rushes to save the boy
and with his exemplary fighting skills
defeats all the soldiers single-handedly
after this the two get on the horse and
proceed to robin's home the loxley hall
sadly when they arrive they find the
house being towed away by a man enraged
robin confronts the man and asks what's
going on the man simply hands him a
scroll and on reading it robin finds out
that prince john has confiscated his
house for failing to pay taxes on time
although robin tries his best to claim
that it was impossible for him to pay
the taxes as he was jailed in jerusalem
the man doesn't listen and takes the
house away as robin wanders the place
dejected he notices his blind servant
blinken the two express their happiness
at meeting each other after so long but
soon robin is devastated when he finds
out that his father has passed away to
make matters worse blanken mentions that
even his mother brothers dog cat and
goldfish perished while he was away as
the two continue talking blinking takes
out a pendant and hands it over to robin
mentioning that it was his father's last
gift for him when robin asks what's
inside it blinken replies that it holds
the key to the greatest treasure in all
the land after a while robin introduces
achoo and blinking to each other as the
trio is talking a boy comes running at
them from the woods being the kind man
that he is robin asks the boy what's
wrong and the boy replies that he is
being chased by the sheriff of
rottingham in no time the sheriff
arrives with his man and demands the boy
back but robin refuses to hand him over
as a result the two get into an
altercation which ends with robin
humiliating the sheriff in front of
everyone before he sends the group away
he vows to take revenge against prince
john later the sheriff of rottingham
meets prince john and reveals that robin
is coming for them here we get to know
that prince john is acting as the ruler
of the kingdom as his brother the king
has gone to fight in the crusades
however instead of being a just and kind
ruler like his brother he is imposing
heavy taxes on people for his own
benefit expectedly the news scares jon
and he starts brainstorming ways to
tackle the situation when he finds no
solution he heads to the dungeons to
take advice from his witch latrine john
briefs everything to his witch and asks
her for a way to defeat robin latrine
agrees to help but in return she asks
jon to assist her hook up with her crush
the sheriff although the prince is sure
that the sheriff will never get close to
the witch he still agrees elsewhere as
robin and his crew are traveling to the
castle they are stopped on a bridge by a
giant named little john robin demands to
let them through but little john claims
that they'll firstly have to pay the
toll tax when robin refuses the two get
into a stick fight despite his small
frame robin manages to defeat the giant
and pushes him into the nearby river
which barely has any water surprisingly
as little john does not know how to swim
he starts drowning in the puddle at
first robin is taken aback but when
little john continues to struggle he
helps him up with this he wins the
giant's trust and makes him a part of
the team before leaving little john
calls his best friend will who happens
to be a dagger expert he can slice
through anything mid-air with his insane
dagger techniques after the
introductions the group of five start
their journey to prince john's castle
meanwhile prince john and the sheriff
are having a party inside the castle
soon john's niece lady marion joins the
duo and observes the celebrations the
sheriff who is infatuated by marion's
beauty immediately starts flirting with
her but the latter pays him no attention
just then robin barges in with a dead
hog on his shoulder and drops it on the
royal table jon and the sheriff are left
furious by the intrusion but
surprisingly lady marion is impressed
nothing like a big hog to curry favor
with the ladies robin then introduces
himself to marion and kisses her on the
hand this enrages the sheriff and he
challenges robin to a fight expectedly
robin cleans the floor with the sheriff
so the prince is forced to call upon his
guards robin fights valiantly for some
time but he is eventually outnumbered
when all hope seems to be lost robin's
gang barges through the door and starts
attacking the guards in no time they
subdue all the bad guys impressing the
entire crowd including lady marion
before leaving robin warns prince john
to reduce the taxes or else he will
eliminate him next time in the next
scene littlejohn gathers some men to
fight for the cause but robin fails to
inspire them with his boring speech
instead he makes them fall asleep seeing
this achoo steps forward wearing his
specks and delivers an inspiring speech
despite it only being three sentences
the crowd gets riled up and they agree
to fight with robin against the
tyrannical prince of england the next
morning all the men get dressed as robin
hoods and start training robin and will
lead the training but the men are so bad
that they cannot even defeat some
dummies meanwhile at the castle the
sheriff invites an italian mafia named
don giovanni to assassinate robin
giovanni has come with his two
associates dirty ezio a mute assassin
and filthy luca a multiple-time gold
medalist in archery after a bit of
chatting the two come to the conclusion
that they will lure robin by organizing
an archery competition in the palace and
filthy luca will defeat him in it when
the crowd turns against robin and calls
him a loser dirty ezio will assassinate
him secretly the plan makes everyone
excited and even dirty ezio who cannot
speak a word starts laughing
surprisingly lady marion is hearing the
entire conversation from her balcony
worried she immediately wakes up her
maid and briefs her about the situation
the two disgust for a while and decide
to sneak out of the castle and warn
robin of the impending danger marion
calls her horse jumps onto it and lands
safely but when its broom held his turn
her horse simply moves away causing her
to drop onto the floor after a while
they reach robin's camp and marion
reveals the sheriff's evil plot to them
at first robin vows to stay out of
trouble but when marion mentions that
the palace is going to organize an
archery competition he starts having
second thoughts even if his life is in
danger he has to attend the festival if
there is an archery competition in it
following this robin puts on a show for
his men and starts singing behind a
curtain in an operatic voice although he
takes out his sword the boys on the
other side of the curtain think that he
has taken out something else after the
performance is over he takes marion to a
secluded place to express his feelings
for her however as he proceeds to make
out with her he realizes that she has
been locked with a chastity belt marion
then reveals that her overly protective
father put the device on her so that she
cannot have any fun before her marriage
hearing this robin knopes out of there i
mean he tries to kiss her but they are
stopped by broom hilda who mentions that
they are getting laid with this the two
depart on their horses but not before
vowing to meet robin again in the next
scene we are taken to the palace where
the annual archery competition is about
to commence several skilled archers have
come from all across the land hoping to
win the ultimate prize as expected
robin's men are also there but they are
disguised as women on the other hand
robin has worn the attire of an old man
soon the competition begins and only two
men are able to hit the bull's eye the
two men are none other than filthy luca
and robin seeing him the sheriff
immediately deduces that it is robin in
disguise meanwhile dirty ezio is hiding
in a nearby tower ready to shoot robin
as the first round between filthy luca
and robin ends in a draw they are
instructed to have one more go at it
robin goes first and once again hits the
bull's eye he then removes his disguise
and reveals himself to be robin much to
the delight of marion however when it is
filthy lucas turn he takes good aim and
pierces through robin's arrow hitting a
double bullseye this gets the crowd
going and they start cheering for filthy
luca at the same time they jeer at robin
and call him a loser robin is in shock
as he is never supposed to lose in an
archery contest hence he takes out the
movie's script to check if everything is
fine luckily he finds out that he has
one more shot left prince john and the
sheriff also check their scripts and
confirm the plot wasting no time robin
takes out his arrow but just as he is
about to shoot filthy luca pushes him
causing him to fire his arrow up
surprisingly the arrow travels through
the air through the entire audience and
lands on the bullseye kobe thus making
him the winner this proves that movie
writers can do anything to make their
heroes victorious as robin celebrates
his victory an envious sheriff orders
his men to arrest and execute him this
worries lady marion so she vows to marry
the sheriff but only if he lets robin go
the sheriff accepts the proposal and
leaves the place to prepare for the
wedding in the next scene a hangman
places a noose on robin's neck just in
case marion changes her mind soon the
sheriff arrives with a minister followed
by marion herself who is dressed
beautifully for the occasion she is
accompanied by her uncle prince john as
robin watches everything unfold the
marriage ceremony begins the sheriff
accepts his vows immediately but when it
is marion's turn she hesitates this
gives achoo an opening and he cuts robin
loose with the help of an arrow with
this an intense battle ensues as robin's
men start fighting with the guards
amidst the chaos the sheriff grabs
marion and forces her into his room
attempting to make love with her however
as he proceeds to deflower her he
notices the chastity lock determined the
sheriff brings a drilling machine and
attempts to break the lock but it's of
no use just then robin enters the room
and challenges the sheriff to a duel the
two go back and forth and during the
action robin's pendant shatters and a
key emerges from it surprisingly the key
lands in the lock and fits perfectly
implying that marion's virginity is the
greatest treasure in the land why did
robin's dad have that key the boys are
distracted for a while but soon resume
their fight after a lengthy tussle robin
accidentally stabs the sheriff with his
sword as the sheriff lies injured on the
floor latrine approaches him and
mentions that she has a pill which can
save him from death however she will
only provide him with it if he promises
to marry her with no options left the
sheriff agrees and after being saved he
is dragged away by latrine in the final
scene of the movie robin and marion get
married in front of everyone just then
the king returns from his crusade and
condemns his brother for being cruel and
evil he orders his men to lock john away
and at the same time rewards robin for
his bravery and valor the king also
returns robin's house and lifts all the
unfair taxes imposed on the people the
movie ends as robin and marion finally
kiss each other in the post-credits
scene as robin tries to deflower marion
he finds out that even with the key the
lock won't open the movie ends as robin
calls for a locksmith
fun fact during the entire course of the
movie prince john's face mole changes
its location several times gross
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching